foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
Jonas
we need your help
we're detecting increased aquatic
activity 25 000 feet deep in the trench
it's an ancient ecosystem Untouched by
men whatever is down there is trying to
make its way to the surface
this was a bad idea just a little bit
foreign
we've got company
I've ever seen
biggest bag anyone's ever seen
that's the apex predator
everybody might get to the station
three massive mags and who knows what
else have escaped the breach
just hope it goes better than last time
what happened last time
you don't want to know
[Applause]
you've never seen this before they
hunted it back
we can relax this place is Meg proof
Venturas was always afraid of this but I
was also thinking
foreign
[Music]